who are some of your favorite characters
what from my own work or
literature let's let's do a couple of
from both
well to get into my favorite character
from literature you have to get into
like my favorite books
and there's so many it's hard to pick a
few but lord of the rings of course is a
book that's had
immense immense impact on me
i read that in junior high school and um
it was like entering another world it
was a reading experience like i'd never
had before and
it almost made me actually give up
wanting to be a writer because i read
that and
i said i can never match what this guy
is doing it's so it's so amazing
and i've reread it many times since but
when i look at that even in that book my
favorite
characters are the gray characters i
mean i think boromir is a fascinating
character
um because he's conflicted he's torn i
mean his motives are good he wants to
save his people he wants to protect his
country
and yet that drives him to potentially
do an appalling thing
and yet then at the end he redeems
himself he gives his life an act of
heroic self-sacrifice
so he's a character who's wonderfully
colored in
in shades of gray and has that level of
complexity around them
strider was another character that i
found interesting and actually i find
him more interesting as strider in the
beginning of the book
than later when he becomes more aragorn
son of aerothorn and he's more the
the perfect prince i like the more
conflicted
scruffier kind of ranger side of his
personality
to get away from science fiction fantasy
the great gatsby is one of my favorite
books
i mean gatsby is another
marvelous character the levels that he
embodies there the
striving to be you know someone born to
a certain lot in life but dreaming of
something better he's the
one of the great archetypical dreamers
in all of literature
but he can never quite reach what he's
dreaming for i mean that symbol at the
end of the book the green light at the
end of daisy's
dock that that he can see but he can't
quite reach it's uh
to my mind that's very moving my own
characters
well vice and fire my favorite character
is tyrion
but to tell you the truth i love them
all i mean
the way i write my characters i my
viewpoint characters in particular
i really have to get inside their head
i'm seeing the world as they see it
trying to think as they would think not
being an authorial god
sitting above them and making judgments
i have to suspend my judgment and get
inside their head
so their actions seem motivated and seem
to be
actually the things that they would do
under those circumstances and i have to
understand them
and all of that requires i think a
certain amount of empathy for them
so it doesn't matter whether i'm writing
about cersei or theon
or one of the characters who might not
be considered a good character
or whatever while i'm inside them i am
them to an extent and
there's a certain amount of affection
there is there any one character that is
no longer
with us that you miss more than than
another you know i miss
all my dead characters um
it's hard to kill them they are like
your children you know there's a story
in dreams called
portraits of his children and that's the
last story in the book actually
and i arranged it that way quite
deliberately it's not the last story
chronologically
but it's the story that most epitomizes
i think the relationship between a
writer and his characters
and to a great extent they actually do
feel like you're your children
you name a chapter in dream songs the
heart
in conflict where does that phrase come
from and what does it mean
the phrase derives from william faulkner
and his uh when he was given the nobel
prize for literature
his acceptance speech which is easily
available on the internet if anybody
wants to google it they can see the
entire text of the speech
but the heart of it was that faulkner
said that the only thing worth writing
about
was the heart and conflict with itself
and i think that's true
you know science fiction in particular
which is a field i've been associated
with over the years
is often called a literature of ideas
and there are some
hardcore science fiction fans and
readers who
seem to think that makes it different
from uh other fields of literature in
some fundamental way and i don't agree
with that
i think all literature has ideas the
great gatsby has many ideas in it they
don't have to be ideas about the boiling
point of water and you know how a pulsar
works
or you know whether you could build a
dyson sphere or not or a new way to get
from one star to another
those are ideas but those are not the
only kinds of ideas ideas about the
human condition
and love and god and
sex and all of these things are also
ideas but the truth is
fiction is not a good is not a good
vehicle for presenting abstract ideas
i mean non-fiction journalism my
profession in which i have my
professional degrees is actually a
better way to explicate and i if you
have an idea about some
political or scientific
method that's why the scientific
journals are full of research reports
they're not full of
science fiction stories what fiction is
good about
is presenting emotion fiction is good
about replicating the human experience
and uh
giving us that and the human heart and
conflict is central to all of that
if the story you're telling me doesn't
have characters in it that i care about
in a situation that's going to engage my
emotions
i'm not going to find it very
interesting also in that chapter you
mentioned something you call the
furniture rules as you're comparing
the different genres sci-fi [ __ ] yes
fantasy
you know i sold my first story in 1970
it appeared in 1971
so i've been at this quite a few years
now and
as a kid i read robert a heinlein
i read h.p lovecraft i read
roberty howard j.r tolkien today
we put those writers in different
categories i mean heinlein is science
fiction
howard and tolkien are fantasy hp
lovecraft
is horror they're distinct genres
they're distinct
marketing labels they're in different
sections of the bookstore that wasn't
really true when i was a kid they were
all my father called it all weird stuff
and you know i could read lovecraft one
day and heinlein the next day i didn't
see any
conflict there it was all kind of the
stuff that i was interested in it all
engaged my imagination as i have written
as i've become a writer in later life
i've written in all of these genres
and i've mixed and matched those genres
to produce some strange sort of hybrids
where
i've done a science fiction horror story
a number of them and a historical horror
story and mixing historical fiction with
horror and
ice and fire in some senses is a mixture
of traditional fantasy tropes with
some of the tropes and feelings of
historical fiction
so i've never been a big fan of genre
boundaries
but i see more and more in modern
publishing people erecting these
boundaries between them publishers seem
to want that i see young writers being
forced if they want to write both
science fiction and fantasy
to adopt different pseudonyms for each
so they have like a science fiction
byline
and a fantasy byline because they don't
want to confuse the reader as to what
you write
i see magazines that say well we only
approach science fiction we don't want
to read fantasy
awards you know every time a fantasy
gets nominated for hugo
there's always some idiots who come out
of the woodwork and say this is a
science fiction award
why is this fantasy being up get it out
of here you know but of course that i
mean
not only are they narrow minded but
they're pig ignorant because the hugo
award if you go all the way back to its
origins in
1952 or whenever was always intended to
include both science fiction and fantasy
and for that matter horror i think
and this stuff drives me crazy in recent
years fantasy has become much more
popular than
science fiction to my mind this is just
cyclical it was just a reverse when i
was breaking in
back in the 70s 60s and 70s science
fiction was much more popular in fantasy
you could hardly find any fantasy these
days fantasy outsells science fiction
someday it'll probably reverse again or
horror will come along we'll sell all of
it more
who the hell knows there are these
trends in that but to my mind it doesn't
matter it's all
imaginative literature and yet you see
some people and it particularly seems to
come from the science fiction side
who really feel that these two things
are antithetical who will
say that oh science fiction is rigorous
and
logical and uh it's precious bodily
fluid should be pure and
fantasy is this mind stuff that'll rot
your mind and all that
i think that argument is tripe i think
these are basically two flavors of
imaginative literature and all that
matters is the furniture
ultimately whether we're writing about
castles or
spaceships or vampires it's still the
human heart in conflict with itself that
matters
and the rest of it is just set dressing
furniture
what have you